okay I'm going to talk to you about the
life cycle of stars now what this means
is how stars are formed and what happens
to them after they essentially die
so we're going to see what happens to
stars now first of all let's start with
the formation of a star they start off
as a nebula now a nebula is just an
enormous cloud of dust and gas so what
happens is there's a force of gravity
that starts to pull all of this dust and
gas together as it does so it's
gravitational energy is converted into
heat energy and we have a rise in
temperature it starts to get really hot
when it gets sufficiently hot we
actually start to get fusion reactions
occurring now what Fusion is is it's
when we have hydrogen nuclei when
they're given when we have the right
conditions of high temperature and
pressure there's enough energy to join
these two hydrogen atoms together and
fuse them so join the fusion just means
joining to make helium this is a fusion
reaction
now when fusion reactions occur they
release loads and loads of energy a huge
amount of energy so with all of these
fusion reactions going on we actually
can create a main-sequence star now our
Sun is currently in this sequence and
this sequence can last for billions of
years now the reason why it can stay
stable is even though there's
gravitational pull pulling everything in
words because of all the fusion
reactions happening in the core there's
also this outwards force from the heat
created by the fusion so as a result it
stays stable and candy for billions of
years now what happens now
is this because there's only a finite
amount of hydrogen for these fusion two
reactions to be happening in the core
one day it will run out when it does run
out we form something called a red giant
this is because all of the hydrogen is
run out in the core and it's caused the
star to swell-up
to this enormous size it becomes red
because the surface is slightly cooler
than it was before now at this point
we've got two different choices of what
can happen depending upon the size of
the original star if we started with
quite a small star we get something
formed called a planetary nebula so
remember whenever we hear the word
planetary whenever we hear the word
nebula we know that it's to do with dust
and gas so planetary nebula we have this
little hot core and then outside of here
we have just dust and gas we've start to
just escape out into space now what
happens to a planetary nebula is all
this dust and gas leaves over time
leaving this really hot core called a
white dwarf now this white dwarf is just
slowly cools over a very very long
period of time so it just cools down and
eventually disappears altogether so
that's the the kind of life of a small
star this is similar to the Sun in our
solar system so this is what will
eventually happen to our son
however with big stars we get something
else happening something a bit more
exciting we get a supernova
and what a supernova is is it the star
start to glow brightly again and they
release an enormous amount of energy now
there's so much energy here in a
supernova that it actually fuses bigger
elements together in our main sequence
star here the only elements that we can
fuse together really well hydrogen which
are really small and simple atoms
whereas in a supernova we can fuse to
get a much much bigger atoms to make
bigger elements such as gold now after I
supernova again we have two potential
different faiths one is a neutron star
now it's just a very dense core left
over from this supernova which is just a
neutron star the other fate and this is
for enormous stars
- absolutely massive stars we get black
holes black holes have such a such a
high gravitational pull that not even
light can escape them so just to quickly
recap a nebula is a cloud of dust and
gas gravity causes it to all kind of
come together as it does it causes an
increase in temperature this temperature
is is high enough to fuse together
hydrogen nuclei this fusion reaction
releases loads of energy that's how we
get a main-sequence star this Sigma star
is stable because the gravity is acting
inwards but few heat from fusion is
acting outwards so it can stay like this
for billions of years when the hydrogen
runs out becomes a red giant it swells
up like this if it's a small star we
then form a planetary nebula which it's
got a core and then some dust and gas
leave it a white dwarf at the end if
it's a big big star then we get
supernovae releasing loads of energy if
I think we then have two different fates
either a neutron star which is just a
dense core or if it's an enormous
enormous star we form a black hole thank
you